we can and must do
better for the oppression of the lesbian
gay by seexual transgender queer and two
spirit communities two we
apologize on behalf of the government
Parliament and the people of
Canada we were wrong we are
sorry and we will never let this happen
again
thank you Mr
Speaker what did that g guy do to the
lesbi why did he do that to the lesbians
what did he do to the two Spirits do you
think how insane do you realize how
insane this all is like it sounds like
he's apologizing for slaughtering two
spirit people which if you slaughter a
two-spirit person how many bodies does
that count as the body count on that
you're going to double that thing